name review welcome everyone to meme
review the most esteemed meme review
show on the planet and today we have a
very very special episode not just meme
of the week not just mean of the year
meme of the decade baby is happening
here keep watching and we will crown it
spoilers it's baby Yoda at least that's
where my vote is going meme review let's
get it right into our first meme talking
to my eggs hey what's up talking to my
wife hi what's up
this takes very brave brain to
understand it's a math joke in case you
didn't understand
it's whatever talking to my eggs talking
to my wife talking to my ex equals my
okay that's talking to Mike ah talking
to my donut very nice but wait there's
more talking to my cosign hey what's
that me and their boys getting a tag me
committing our exchange that's illegal
in at least fifty four states stop this
man Oh a narc sent I see it now let me
zoom in sorry in case you guys don't get
it
yeah that's funny laughs alright I
understand this name too complicated for
your tiny little brain
let's dumb it down a bit you've heard of
Xbox now it's ready for why box they
named it wrong all this time it really
should be the Y box it makes you
question why you bought it
speaking of Xbox have you seen this
thing it looked like the square from Tom
and Jerry that's where this is the new
way of multi-layer marketing where
brands just make it their product the
deliberately goofy-looking so people
will be like haha it looks stupid
meanwhile Xbox is like a free marketing
baby oh yeah look at these fools I don't
understand this one why is there two of
them they're all here we got the four
horsemen the really shapes 2019 tech you
got the lope
the truck you have the electric shaver
you have the PC with an Xbox logo on it
you have the head cheese grater and you
have the headphones that look like that
one Pokemon I'm sold
I don't know about you guys but I for
one am sold on this thing I swear by the
X God I swear I mean I feel like
spongebob has to be the meme of the
decade almost but that's just cuz it's
so good it looked like fridge I wonder
what kind of snack you can get from that
Xbox x-series Wow delicious I'm gonna
rate this an Xbox because I'm that
creative thank you thank you
moving on to cheating meme fellas I have
a very important question to you fellas
out there y'all takin her back or no did
you freak him yes oh my god what a tough
what a tough question the answer that
would literally take a man's soul from
his body did you make eye contact with
him no no you ate my leftovers didn't
it's getting heated into space you eat
my leftovers marriage over Marcia those
are the rules I've said it many times
Marcia do not touch my leftovers and do
not I repeat and do not let anyone else
play with my playstation are we clear
lol I glued henge to my face oh my hands
I can't read so that was funny or the
way I read it did you vibe with him was
it the guy that uses three-in-one
shampoo Oh God well he's clearly
deserves to freak my wife then what an
absolute alpha this meme zero it's kind
of bad I don't know all right while
we're in the zone of really stale memes
let me just throw this one in here I've
seen her a couple of times but I just
want to acknowledge it it's the ape
together strong meme when the school's
idiot and the high kid do a project
together and it turns out to be good ape
together strong netflix joined forces
with nickelodeon to take on disney apes
to get out strong vaccines causes
seizures a
together still weak aims together
dumbest Apes together literally Final
Fantasy seven hentai found in Osama bin
Laden's 2011 compound weebs together
strong I feel like there has to be
better captions today these are so stale
my dad how about this I got nothing
this mean another zero how about that
all right
meme of the decade I know you're waiting
for it spoilers its baby Yoda next mean
so this means I've been popping up I
don't know what to call it but it goes a
little something like this imagine you
have to use your feet to measure
something yeah this meme was made by the
European gang and not UK I guess it
still makes sense things brexit now this
may make sense hey I didn't have to pay
for your ambulance made by countries
outside of you it's gang well maybe the
ambulance will actually incumbant
Jesus Christ it's so bad here imagine
making music and not being able to hear
it Wolf Gang Gang Gang Gang get it
imagine actually needing bullets this
poster was made by scoped knife gang
damn
imagine having to pay for candy this
poster was made by kidnap kings gang
damn I don't know which gang I'm in
there's so many great gangs imagine not
being it's sort of more and more
transition into weaponry I don't know
why it's weird imagine not being able to
get a head shot every time this pose was
made by guillotine gang well it clearly
wasn't made by face game because those
helis gets freaking heck headshot
imagine people reading the right this
poses made by the bad handwriting gang
imagine guys imagine imagine freaking
dying lmao their supporters made by
queen elizabeth ii gang that's a gang
I'd be into damn gang I don't know the
Queen was in a gang that makes me kind
of concerned
imagine having to stick a flip-flop
inside your gun to have it shoot this
poster is made by pump shotgun gang damn
this is getting aggressive
imagine having to finger your weapon to
do anything maybe
my broken bottle gang Oh imagine having
guns these are made by our Australia
gang and anywhere in Europe gang imagine
hi oh god oh god imagine having your
chair stuck to the desk like a child
those made by loose chair gang no post
loose chair gang for life that's what
I'm talking about that's where it's at
loose chair gang but can chair dude
imagine giving your gun a [ __ ] before
each shot this pass was made but I did
it-- yeah I said passed imagine not
being able to launch a 90 kilo object
over 300 meters these posters made by
trebuchet gag trebuchet gang wins
everyone congratulations - Trevor
shaking sometimes I wish I was a
trebuchet it's not fair
[Music]
me why was I not born like trebuchet
it's not fair
Oh what's that we have news updates from
Popish Maria
[Music]
good evening Papas Moria here
big news happening Takeshi 69 sentenced
to two years in prison we've been long
awaiting for what since Takeshi six and
would get and he's been ruled 13 months
in prison for racketeering charges
because he ratted out all his friends
Takeshi 6:9 was sentenced to two years
prison after snitching on his gang
that's it that's it wait so he went to
prison for snitching what that's it
judge you're sentenced to two years in
prison we also now have live footage of
tech se six nines reaction to the
sentencing here we go this is also me
when I was born and realized I was in a
trebuchet
it's like brah s and freakin H next me
the bite of 87 the bite of 87 is that
bite of 87 over there I don't really
follow the Lord from Fri nights at
freddys but I know all the time in the
first game the bite of 87 is reference
and then memeing that has become a meme
thanks to markiplier why we it is funny
though
I don't Witter I hate twit there was
that like of 87
[Laughter]
the bite of 87 it must have been it
could have not have been anything else
markiplier Mike did it congratulations
markiplier we finally figured out the 87
yes this mean gets if 87 very oh there's
one more to bite of 87 was that the bite
of 87 I think so I think it must have
been the bite of 87 now for the time
that we all wait oh wait there's one
more meme next name alright don't be
disappointed
alright but it's literally just this
this is cat doing the thinking thing
it's doing the processing thing because
it looks like it's making that face this
is supposed to be a gif and the joke is
that they wasted their time making this
gif but I couldn't get the oh wait here
we go
alright it's working never got there you
go well that's pretty cool when you see
an HD version of a popular meme template
or how about this one
nice weather today thanks you're welcome
good evening I'm Popish Maria returning
back again important news raid shadow
legends have been overtaken by flying
gorilla in ratings sweet victory at last
have a great day and smash like on this
video and suck it raid shadow of legend
flying guerrilla game of year we don't
know what to meme of decade this but
with no game of decade flying gorilla
always another news Person of the Year
went to great a tune bag I don't know
how to say her name it's very Swedish
don't know how to pronounce the stinky
language I love this poll that was from
what is that you would say today who
should be times 2019 Person of the Year
nah nah it's greater turn back we also
have a couple bonus memes girls I only
had six hours of sleep I'm so tired boys
I get it because I play Minecraft I also
like this one because it's true it's the
most meta meme of the year well done
well done
and finally meme of the decade Vox the
pinnacle of journalism what is their
idea of meme of the decade where they
brought up double rainbow that was a
good meme right double rainbow yeah sure
don't even put that on the list alright
meme of the decade has to be something
that will go on beyond the decade right
don't even can bring it up Mel one says
double rainbow Rebecca flack bar day can
bloom blow my slings look cute they put
up Coney it's not even asking me Mew
dumbasses dodge no one uses charge not
even ironically Slenderman no one hey I
get it these are popular memes in their
self in their own little encapsulation
but they are not I repeat not worthy
what the [ __ ] is this on fleek didn't
die look they even can bring up baby Oda
an ironic Lee baby Oda a meme that's
lasted what three weeks meme of decade
potentialize I think this has meme of
decade potential I don't know about you
guys but I think baby Oda has a lot of
potential to transpire and like last for
another decade I think so
but when I first saw these memes is
talking about when Normie say baby Yoda
should be meme of decades sounds like
it's not is anyone actually saying that
and I was like oh god people actually
are oh this is ridden by the dumb ass
if that wrote an article of me hahaha oh
my god the dumb curry how do you get so
stupid
this is Pepe the Frog yep easily one of
the most iconic memes and of the decade
and has remained relevant ever since
uh-huh
so he should be meme of the decade makes
sense to me so vote for Pepe baby Yoda
Yoda my votes for baby Yoda I think baby
Yoda another fair argument is for the
earth to pay respect when everyone is
voting for me with a decade or meme of
the year but you made your way into
people's language I think that's a
pretty fair point right that's what me
mother Dec it should be something that
will go on and live on and forever and
it will prosper and live greatness but
it seems like doggy wins though I don't
know I don't really care I don't know
what to tell you
[Music]
when everyone's fighting over number one
meme of the decade but no one is going
for second place its famous I'll take
I'll take you like fifth place if I can
when you don't hear your name mentioned
for me mother nature although you
assured in the meme Golden Age punished
haram the fallen legend now it cannot go
to around me I refused baby order for
meme of decade normies the entire meme
community who's your meme of the decade
what do you guys think let me know in
the comments down below
romance it for me for now hope you
enjoyed this episode of meme review and
I see you guys next time
hey Doc hey d'Or hottie bra does history
hey that video isn't over yet okay KK
existed to be important super important
me and my it says clothing brand Sookie
has done a collaboration with Jill a 2pk
it's a Japanese friend that we really
like you can check it out at geological
us we designed our own pajama and the
fabric is amazing it's so comfy I'm
super happy how they turn out
so if you're interested in that check it
out that's it thanks for watching bye
bye